[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we are back it felt like a
longer than usual break I think for me
part of it was that almost the entire
week before the break I was broadcasting
remotely so my presence was basically
missing from the studio for thirteen
days which is I don't know it was a
while it felt like a long time for me
too but I think that was just because it
was so eventful when you do a lot of
stuff and you're flying and different
visiting different cities that you've
never been to before the time feels like
it's slowing down a bit well that's good
cuz usually it's like before you know it
it's December and the year is over so
Pat had a great trip he went to London
Paris and Brussels you if I recall
correctly had never been to London or
I'm sorry you had been to London you had
never been to Paris and Brussels what
was the how would you summarize the trip
big picture European okay it was
probably the best vacation I've ever
gone on I loved every second of it I
loved visiting Europe as you mentioned I
had been to London so it's kind of like
comparing apples and oranges when I
compare London to Paris and Brussels in
the sense that apples and oranges are
both fruits and all of those are
different cities in Europe yeah but I
think Paris was was certainly my
favorite city that I went to on this
visit I would say it's my favorite city
in Europe Wow I love just the age of
everything I think just even being out
on the street everything just looks so
beautiful and mold and you can tell with
the architecture there's so much
attention to detail right I loved every
minute of it it was a great vacation
what do you think is so special about
Paris other than the architecture
because it has a genus a quoi
oh sure that is hard to describe to
others and some in some sense but well
how would you characterize it oh man
it's just like I think I think you can
you say this about many European cities
but I love just being in an atmosphere
where you feel as if this is a place
that has been around for such a long
time and so much has happened here like
you can go to the conquered palace
and that's like the site of the French
Revolution and so many executions were
taking place there now you can go there
and like buy an ice cream and go on the
ferris wheel right and you just you feel
the history and it's like it's all there
with you and I loved every second of
that I don't know I mean I just when you
go and you see something that's built in
like the Year 1100 or 1200 right it's
just it feels so amazing because we have
nothing to compare that to yeah it makes
a New England house from 1890 just not
seem that interesting when you go and
you see that the really old stuff is
from the 1112 hundreds and then you've
got less old stuff from the 1600 and
1700s
now the question everybody wants to know
is did you stick to your vegan diet the
entire time and how much Soylent did you
have ahead a different meal replacer
than soil and it's called joylent okay
which is like a powder thing so I drink
one shake of that every day and that's a
good 700 calories to start me off okay
the England I did fight do you know why
because I speak the language fluently
right not as well as the Brits do but I
was able to communicate either I didn't
even have to say I Egan I could just you
know make sure that I'm getting like the
beans from the hash browns and things
are gonna be okay with me right France
it was not as easy
veganism is not prominent there no and
also I don't speak the language I can
say two sentences in French one is I
don't speak French and the other is I'm
not a pineapple okay it's a story for a
different day so like I you know I'm
like looking at the menu I'm trying to
use like the cognate sino from English
and Spanish to determine what these
words mean right uh but it was a
guessing game so yes I did eat a little
bit of cheese you did I did eat probably
some dairy and some butter and stuff it
was not intentional it was not
intentional what was gonna say oh so you
didn't intentionally have no but I'm
dealing with wait staff that doesn't
necessarily speak English I'm pointing
at the menu again once I order something
it's like the damage has been done
okay you know if there's like a little
cheat I'll like set aside the things on
the plate and my girlfriend could eat it
no let me talk let me talk I think the
best I can
okay when what is the item that you
think like almost definitely you ate not
vegan well there was like there was some
cheese and a salad so cheese you're
aware of as definitely not vegan that
was yeah that was nicer
like I could like pick it apart you know
okay I'm sure I'm sure they cooked with
some butter okay cuz I could like kind
of taste that and I had to just kind of
like you know hold my nose and get
through it
Wow no I'm not a perfect person I'm not
a perfect vegan but I mean once I've
ordered the thing and has come to my
table what options do I have
yeah get another meal I mean wait what
good is that gonna do right what's gonna
suck it up Wow
did you drink Parisian espresso yes you
did although my girlfriend wanted to
drag me to like Starbucks or over God
because that's what she knows right and
she wants to get like a pure rush of
caffeine not just like the simple
espresso shot or cappuccino and I had to
push her like no we're at a different
land here we got to live like the
Parisians
and we can't do the Starbucks thing I'm
just not gonna have it that is
disturbing quite frankly that is very
very disturbing yeah what was the most
notable thing that happened big picture
okay um well you know I obviously saw
like the big sights right I don't have
to get into like going down Big Ben and
you know going to the top of the Eiffel
Tower and all that stuff because that's
that's pretty simple crossing Abbey Road
to get the picture very touristy thing
to do
yeah but it's also a whole bunch of fun
because first of all there's like a
dozen other people trying to do the same
thing so everyone's kind of waiting
their turn but also you have to wait for
the right opportunity because it'd be
perfect yeah because it's an active road
yeah and cars are passing by non-stop
and I think most a majority of the the
people driving understand that these are
tourists trying to get their their nice
picture yeah and and they're respectful
of it and they'll wait and you know kind
of deal with it but then you get like
this twenty percent of people who are
just on their horns and very pissed off
that the tourists are doing this but we
got the picture right I mean it took a
few times but yeah it was just like a
fun experience I don't know if you when
you went to London do you do the same
thing it's a very touristy thing to do I
didn't do that no no I didn't okay yeah
I'm somehow not surprised alright what
else did you okay John alright Oh a
pickpocketing story from France
I knew ahead of going there that there's
a bunch of pickpocketing in France you
gotta be wary of it you got to watch
your pockets and I made sure to put my
wallet in my backpack for the entire
trip hmm what were you clothes over
there act behind you yep okay that
doesn't seem so smart
as compared to putting in your pockets
the hot pocket front but yes no really
well yeah I think hiding it at the
bottom of the backpack below like
sweatshirts oh I should ends ippon it up
is safer than just having it in your
pocket so all I did was I keep my cell
phones in my pockets and I went you know
through the first two three days in
Paris not experiencing anything that was
concerning I didn't think I would get
pickpocketed and maybe just people are
blowing this out of proportion right
right so I felt you know a little bit
safe but I'm still keeping the wall in
the backpack I'm at the the arc what's
the famous Arc de Triomphe
ugly troll and I'm going to from there
to the Eiffel Tower so imagine it's a
very touristy area although it's
probably part of a line that extends
into the suburbs and whatnot I step on
the subway I kid you not like a second
after I get on the subway a guy holding
on to the pole drops an inhaler and a
few other things like some pens just to
create some chaos right and also the
inhaler kind of gives you this image of
like oh this this poor guy can't breathe
very well you got to be concerned about
him
so he like he reaches down to grab the
inhaler and screeching a bunch of other
stuff he's like a foot away from me the
guy grabs onto my leg
literally just holds on to my leg and he
starts exclaiming my ticket my ticket is
in your shoe so once this happens like I
know because there are pickpocketers
here I put my hands right in my pockets
where I'm you know my cell phone is to
protect it yeah a little bit and he just
like he keeps holding on and you know
like the first two or three seconds
obviously I was very confused and I saw
the inhaler so I was like alright I
can't be incredibly mean to the guy
getting the benefit of the doubt but it
just went on too long but he said my
ticket in English yeah huh who's he
probably knew was a touristy area and
the guy knew what he was doing right
right
I think what he was trying to do was
either like hold on to my leg for long
enough that a friend of his some like
cohort could reach behind and in the
chaos reach into my pocket and leave it
before it left but luckily you know
being a city person I wasn't going to be
fooled by it and so I kept my hands in
my pockets for like the first two or
three seconds and then once he wasn't
letting go of my leg I like kicked him I
really like I had the fear the first
kick rushed him off of me and then like
it wasn't like I guess strike it was
like a push kick right and then like
he's like he's because he was on the
ground from the get-go it's like it was
a hard thing to do like on the ground
right and then ii was like a strike like
i kicked him off the train when the
doors closed and you're like yeah it was
so close a bunch of chaos no people
didn't clap i've been like I still had
to like check do I have everything like
wow I still like check my pockets I like
looked in the backpack like and I was
pretty startled by it that it was
disturbing yeah and you don't have to
after you have like a traumatic
experience or something where you just
think that you didn't perform as well as
you could have you like play it back a
bunch of times yeah yeah I could have
done this differently or should I I was
still getting that even though
everything went just fine
like I still had all my stuff I was
saved my girlfriend was safe like things
could not have gone better really and
I'm sure the guy wasn't hurt like I mean
it was it wasn't the strongest weaker
anywhere would you say the kik connected
I liked his chest check yeah Wow and
like it was like it pushed him back like
wow I was it was pretty heroic I gotta
say please send me the memes related to
this story I beg you yeah the the Arc de
Triomphe is were actually where my
girlfriend and I were almost sort of
pseudo scammed or a guy came up and he
said excuse me you dropped the ring and
he appears to pick up a ring off of the
ground and both of us say no that's
that's not a ring and he says oh well
it's a gift for you and he puts it on my
girlfriend's hand and she says uh okay
and he's like do you you know one two
euro and she just takes it off and hands
it back to it okay
no and I'm sure he just goes around
doing that yeah like how though that
that's nothing compared to what you
experienced right and I felt like I
wasn't really prepared for it because I
always just thought that pickpocketers
go in and like reach into your pocket
and you never even knew they were there
right I didn't realize that had all
these different plans and different
avenues to pursue yes that's so like I
was startled by it for a little bit it
took a little while before I felt
comfortable again that's uh I really
really do fortunately nothing bigger
happened I guess what I would say all
right so I'll talk a little bit about my
trip I was in Vegas of course then I
went to for the conference then I loo to
Los Angeles to visit former TV director
natandy at man rented a car drove north
through basically a number of different
places stopped in a bunch of places
Santa Barbara San Luis Obispo
Monterey ultimately terminating the trip
in San Francisco spending a couple of
days there and then flying home and so
first of all at the conference in Vegas
this was Mike Papantonio conference
there were people from all sides of the
left so to speak the we believe the
Russia story is a hoax side the we
believe there is a Russia story side and
so on and so forth so there were some
very interesting disagreements that took
place at the conference none of which I
participated in because I wasn't there
to debate politics with people but Sam
cedar certainly participated in some of
those debates saw Genk huger there saw a
lot of the Ring of Fire people saw ed
Schultz's producer saw some people from
RT a lot of different people there and I
think my message is the left is very
very divided but all elements of the
left were still able to sort of be
cordial and have dinners together and
that did not evolve it did not devolve
into partisan bickering so maybe more
diverse than divided then it was a
diverse set of views rather than a
divided set sure so that's that and you
know I go to the conference twice a year
not not really anything else to report
from there I had just a horrible
experience at the hotel in Los Angeles
and I'm not even gonna say what hotel it
was doesn't really matter but I was
staying in Los Angeles with my
girlfriend for three nights we checked
in and I was told oh uh checking out
tomorrow right I said no not not
checking out tomorrow I'm here I'm here
three nights mmm no no you have a
one-day reservation one night
reservation but uh doesn't really make
sense here's you know my whatever all my
information oh you know what happened
for some reason your three night
reservation got split into a one night
reservation and a two night reservation
I'm gonna combine them for you so that
everything will be all set no problem
whatsoever
I get into the room and the room stinks
to high heaven of some kind of perfume
they it's one of these hip hotels where
they have like a unique scent that's
sprayed everywhere but particularly in
the rooms
everything on the bedding on the pillows
in the bathroom everywhere and
immediately my skin starts to react to
it like I'm allergic to this scent I
start getting itchy and red all over so
I call down and I say listen I don't
know what it is that smells in here
the room's fine everything's fine but
I'm I think I'm allergic to whatever it
is that your spring and they immediately
said oh that's our signature scent we're
gonna send out our tea but I don't even
want to use all the words they use
because it'll probably make it evident
but anyway they they don't call it
housekeeping they're they call it our
style team I like it we're gonna send
our style team up to neutralize the
scent it's gonna be no problem for you I
went out to dinner went out for with
with my brother and a few other friends
Bubba Bo Bob I get back they did do a
good job of neutralizing the scent but
it's 55 degrees in the room because
they've opened up the windows and it was
a cool night and set the AC to max I
guess to get rid of that scent to like
get it out through the vents and through
the windows or whatever so the rooms
freezing no problem they've neutralized
the scent close the window set the AC to
a normal temperature it looks like
everything's okay okay next day I get up
I go out I come back and it's about 5:00
p.m. and I go to the elevator and you've
got to you know put your your card your
room card up for the elevator to work
and the red light comes on doesn't let
me up the elevator not thing that's
weird maybe the car yesterday became
demagnetized my girlfriend takes out her
card she puts it up to the thing red
light were blocked out from the elevator
now immediately I think back to I had a
one night reservation and a two night
reservation I think what happened is
they didn't fix the problem and I've
been checked out because I had a one
night reservation as far as their
computer was concerned check out is noon
it's 5:00 p.m.
I'm out okay I go to the front desk and
I hand them my card and I say I'm unable
to get into the room into the elevator
they say well checkout time was at noon
mr. Pakman and it's 5:00 p.m. and I say
no I'm here for two more days
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh they eventually get
it fixed I get into the room in the same
room that same rooms good yeah I get
into the room
it stinks again they've resurfaced why
because the note not to spray it on my
reservation was only there for the one
night resumption not for the second
nights and within five minutes clearly
when I actually went into the room
something was flagged security shows up
and they say mr. Pakman we're here about
your departure time yeah you're supposed
to go in hours ago I just dealt with
this for the second time oh my god I'm
here for two more days so anyway you
know not not a great not a great
experience there but beautiful bedding
absolutely beautiful bedding and and my
back felt great from the mattress did
you notice that other people were
complaining about the scent too or do
you think just because you were allergic
to it
that's why you were so averse to the
smell I know that other people were
complaining about it from the reaction
when I called down and I said listen I
don't know if there's like a perfume or
a cleaning product I said oh it's our
signature scent we'll send our team up
there it was a Senate it was very
obvious that it's a common problem so
that was that I had an interesting
experience we're walking through Beverly
Hills I the previous night I had been
talking with my brother and some of his
friends about what shows we're currently
watching and I mentioned the Americans
is back great program I love the
Americans margo martindale is in the
show she's great
Frank Langella is in the program he's
great walking through Beverly Hills
very nice sports car pulls up hmm I look
over and then I do a double take and
it's Frank Langella of the Americans and
of many other great programs and movies
sitting there on speakerphone 80
year-old guy working speaker phone while
driving very very advanced guy for 80
and he probably has a similar story I
was just driving by and David Pakman
said I saw Frank Langella other than
that had a great time in California love
San Francisco San Francisco continues to
be one of my favorite cities in the
country
I do like LA although spending 45
minutes in the car no matter where you
want to go is not exactly the best thing
a lot of emails from people asking if
the show was canceled which happens
every time we go on vacation a lot of
emails from people saying that they know
we're on vacation but it would be really
great if I could cover X because it
happened
like the Michael Cohen stuff or whatever
and of course I'm driving through you
know rural in a hostile California not
exactly a situation times a live stream
about Barbara Bush right I couldn't do
it but other than that a good trip all
flights were on time and I made it back
safely and it was a good good vacation
did he stick to the cities for the most
part I think ahead of the vacation you
were talking about going up to the Big
Sur and maybe singing like some national
parks because there is a lot of unity at
that part of the country stopped in some
small places like Pismo Beach is a place
that we stopped in which is like an old
hippie community outside of San Luis
Obispo stopped in Monterey which is near
Big Sur drove through Big Sur but
because of timing wasn't able to stop
there but did stop in Monterey which is
another beautiful little coastal town so
yeah I got to see some of the coastal
coastal area successful vacation then
very successful I I really like it out
there you know it's an area where if I
there's only a few places that I've been
to in the US where I could really see
myself living Boston New York City Miami
San Francisco you know there's not a
huge huge list Austin Texas maybe
Western Mass where I grew up I do like
it there San Francisco is a great spot
sometimes I feel like I'm Matt Damon
from Good Will Hunting yeah and I think
that I could never live anywhere except
for Boston like this is just the place
for me right but I don't think you have
that feeling because no we were not even
born and raised here no I wasn't I could
definitely live in places other other
than Boston so anyway very very exciting
trip no no fainting for me on airplanes
no car breakdowns for you which I was an
issue last time you had a trip you know
I remember now that you mentioned that
as I was landing to go to Iceland
because I was nice one for a layover
like the last 10 20 minutes of the
flight I did feel a little bit
lightheaded really and I was a little
bit sick like I had a tiny bit of a cold
because I get that when I'm traveling
sometimes especially if you're drinking
different water and exposed to different
elements I don't know if just drinking
London water gives you a cold but Oh
care enough got well so I've read yeah
and I thought for a second like I could
pass out here because of just the
altitude difference and the pressure my
sinuses were very you know
logged up and I was like am I gonna pull
a pac-man here right on the plane in
front of everyone so it was a confusing
medical diagnosis but one which
nevertheless left you feeling as though
you could potentially faint but you
didn't fortunate right Wow Wow
well that's good I'm glad you didn't
faint it's not a good experience on a
plane although at least you were close
to landing when it happened to me I was
above Greenland halfway between Rome and
Boston okay one really quick thing Sam
cedar suggested to me that I create a
website instead of talking about david
pakman.com slash membership
he said create a website is simple calm
that will redirect to the membership
sign-up page like he has one called like
join the majority report or something
like that calm so he had the idea joined
the pact PA k done calm it's taken and
the guy who owns the URL wants $1,000
for it just not worth it okay so i'm
open to ideas from the audience
join pakman.com is available Pakman
membership calm is available i know that
by mentioning these anybody could go pay
the ten bucks and register it whatever
if you really are desperate to ruin what
i'm doing go ahead i don't think our
members would but my question to you is
what URL simple URL should i by and
redirect it to the membership page so
that instead of promoting david
pakman.com slash membership i can just
promote something like join pakman.com
send me your thoughts please via email
david at david pakman.com i will make a
decision and we will get the URL senate
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]